[Music]
[Applause]
bring in our good buddy Sean Salisbury
former NFL quarterback host of the Sean
Salisbury show on Sports Talk 790 in
Houston let me start with something that
was just brought up again by a listener
do you think Lamar Jackson's contract
status has anything to do with his
availability against the Bengals this
weekend
I would hope not Dan because I'd go back
to the preseason
when he could have said I'm not showing
up like we've seen guys do in the past
and not play the the the regular season
um maybe it's sitting on the point where
the frustrations started to build and a
teammate of his and roquan Smith got
paid
um maybe at all the the cumulative
effect Dan but I'd like to think and I'm
gonna give Lamar more credit than that
to think that if considering Legacy and
on the line that he and his were places
people don't talk about but him and
thinking about it that with a chance to
do something he hasn't done and get to a
Super Bowl I think he'd like to do it
I'm in the back of his mind you don't
want to get hurt but I think he would
have done it at the beginning not the
end I think that he's probably just not
fit and ready to play
you of course cover the Texans they lost
the number one pick and we were
wondering in the moment
if you if if you get the touchdown now
it's a fourth and 20. and you're going
to go for a two-point conversion
um You're Gonna Lose the number one
overall pick now now Lovey Smith is
trying to save his job and Davis Mills
is trying to save his job as the
starting quarterback I understand all
those things but if you're management
could you have somehow got a message
down to say let's run an elaborate
two-point conversion that we know might
not succeed so we can get the number one
team a number one pick there
well I'd have spread it out of the Press
Box as a general manager and I'd have
knocked his ass out before he made the
play call that's what I had done dad is
there is such thing as a crappy win that
was it now
no doubt about it because number one is
Lovey Smith wasn't saving his job I I
guarantee you they knew going into that
that he wasn't coming back because they
didn't just wake up after the game said
I think we'll fire him they knew going
in that no matter what even if they'd
have won by 40 Dan he wasn't going to
keep this job so yeah I would have said
first off Davis Mills yeah we want you
to I know we want to showcase you but I
think we're going to run the inside Zone
read with Jeff Driscoll the whole game
that's how you control it because you
know Dan players and coaches are like
even if you know you're not going to get
fired or R you're like screw that I'm
gonna leave it all on the table and so
are the players Davis Mills doesn't want
you drafted Bryce young or CJ Stroud so
of course they're gonna play it now I
got to tell you it sure as heck also
looked like the cold I mean when you
jump up and the ball goes through your
hands and you're going like that and
completely missing it's like come on get
a stop on two fourth downs but yeah I
would have created it in the in the week
leading up to it I would have all of a
sudden about eight players have hammy
problems they wouldn't have played I
wouldn't have let it happen Dan because
it sure sounds a lot better to control
the draft as the one pick yeah
especially a team that needs it then the
two pick regardless of who you want to
take
are the Texans attractive enough for
Sean Payton to strongly consider taking
that job if offered well you heard Nick
casario say if there's a coach that
wants the job or doesn't like what I'm
doing I'll step aside sure you will no
you won't
um you know the the talk of Sean wanting
to bring in like a Jeff Ireland a guy he
can stand shoulder to shoulder with now
sometimes you may say that then all of a
sudden a guy grabs you and says I'm the
guy for you and the head coach and the
and the GM which I believe Dan both have
to be Alphas but take eagle and pride
aside and even if you disagree on
certain things you got to be able to
discuss it and talk it out that hasn't
been the case here they've hired coaches
that they expected to be Bridge coaches
to this situation hell if you're Nick
casario hire a guy for selfish reasons
to save your job
um attractive enough Dan great plenty of
room in the salary cap all these assets
uh Texas is a great place to coach
football the problem is the trust and
the dysfunction does Sean Payton believe
that even he can fix the dysfunction
that's gone on in this building if he
had his own guy he probably would for
him probably not Dan because I think he
wants his own guy but it is an
attractive job if you can sift through
the trust and dysfunction which is a big
big sift through here in Houston if
you're the Bears GM are you trading
Justin fields and taking Bryce Young
I'm not I've seen it because I'm not
sure five years from now as much as I
love Bryce young and I think he's got
that it factor that that we can't teach
it's just there and it's not just
potential Dan I've seen production you
know we talk about potential potential
gets coaches fired production and
potential together lead you to places
like Trevor Lawrence has done and
Herbert and Burl I think Bryce Young's
got that I'm not big on the measurables
I think they're overrated I need can the
guy win for me and Elevate everybody in
the building and maximize I think Bryce
young can but if I can continue to see
growth with Justin Fields if I was
Chicago I would not trade that pick I
would not trade Justin Fields now if
somebody I'm listening to every call if
you're going to make me three
first-round pick offers then I'd
probably do it because I don't think I'm
going to lose much I've seen enough
adjusting fields to tell me there is
growth there and potential and I'm not
sure in five years who's going to be
better fields of Bryce young he's got to
improve as a passer but with all the
things that you need I think there's
still room to get Justin fields to grow
but I'm going to answer the bat phone to
every call you make but my priority is
not to trade Justin fields for a college
quarterback
um just yet
if I got a good
um offer for Justin Fields then I would
trade him if because if I think Bryce
young and Justin fields are similar I
can reset the quarterback clock with
Bryce young 100 and I didn't mean to
interrupt you down yeah but Justin
Fields is that's not sustainable
it's great to watch it's not sustainable
and we've watched this down through
history you know Bryce young can be more
sustainable and I can reset the clock
maybe I get a first round and a third
round pick for Justin Fields something
yeah maybe it no if the if the offer is
like that where it is I'm gaining assets
first round if you give me like what
they got for Trey Lance Let's just say
for instance what the 49ers gave up
right man in the draft to get Trey Lance
or something in that if you were to get
that there's no doubt because you're
exactly right sustainability we've seen
it it looks good but I can tell you this
we don't win Super Bowls by starting a
guy who can extend the pocket and then
once in a while beat you from inside it
we win Super Bowls from the hula hoop in
the pocket and then if we can extend the
play and go to Great Championship
quarterbacks got to beat you throwing on
time with accuracy and throwing people
open so if you make me an offer I can't
refuse I'm with you because do I believe
Bryce uh Bryce young can walk into the
Chicago Bears and make them better
overnight I don't know about seven games
better but you're damn right I do so but
it has to be an offer that I won't let
out of the building because I can reset
and I think Bryce young right now is a
far better guy inside the tackles than
Justin Fields but it better be an offer
I can't refuse Sean Salisbury former NFL
and UNC quarterback host of the Sean
Salisbury show Sports Talk 790 in
Houston
um
Tom Brady to the Dolphins Mike Florio
floated that
same Source Who told him when you know
Tom was going to go there with Sean
Payton and then yeah the Brian Flores
lawsuit now he's bringing it back up
again you could keep two on the roster
Tom comes in and he also floated the
idea Sean Payton going to the Dolphins
which would mean Mike McDaniel would be
a one and done having taken this team to
the playoffs right the likelihood that
Tom Brady would go to the Dolphins is
what in your opinion
I think higher than we think I think
you'd throw the Raiders into it because
of Josh McDaniels I think the likelihood
that Tom Brady plays again and maybe
somewhere else is more likely that than
he retires Dan even all that what 375
million that's waiting on him
um I don't think but I got to tell you
they're going to beat the Dallas Cowboys
on Monday night and this dude in January
doesn't lease it or rent it they're
going to win on money they're going to
win on Monday night now they're getting
healthier listen I know the record says
they have been good but think about the
NFC quarterbacks if I took every NFC
quarterback and stuck every one of them
in Philadelphia who do you trust the
most in January Dan
Tom Brady so it's tended with Tom walk
from Tampa maybe but can I see in Miami
him going to Miami which is obviously
the talk about him wanting to go but
Sean I trust Brady in January I don't
trust this team in January that's my oh
I trust him more than I trust the way
the Dallas Cowboys are up and down like
the Dow Jones and Dak throwing the ball
to the other team because they were
going to cut it Loose defensively I
don't think they can win a Super Bowl
with the way they've played I said if
you took all the NFC quarterbacks Now
The Gauntlet of the afc's brutal friggin
brutal but you took them all all those
quarterbacks in the NFC and said you
have the same roster San Francisco's
roster Phillies roster Dallas's roster
who do you trust the most you're taking
12 in Tampa you just are on any of those
rosters now I trust Philly's team more I
trust the 49ers see more but Dan that's
why I'm saying we're talking about a 45
year old who in January still can make
enough plays the question is can I keep
him upright and can he play well if that
turns it over a couple times Tampa's
winning at home now as far as his future
I can see Tom playing in another uniform
wearing number 12. Sean Payton what's
not to love about that it'd be weird to
watch Mike McDaniel leave after one
season and get into the playoffs but if
you can get Brady no offense to Tua
you're a better football team with Tom
Brady and Sean Payton than you are with
Tua and uh Sean Payton there's no
question about it
I don't know what the Rams are doing
because if I'm running the Rams I say to
Sean McVay
come on in today
and you're not going to leave the
building until you make a decision
because because I have coaches who are
now free to leave like I have to run a
team I I'm not running a Sean what do
you want to do with your life I'm
running a football team
why aren't the Rams saying to Sean McVay
You Can't Hold Us hostage we want you
back or you want to take a year off take
the year off you know we'll we'll bring
in somebody on an interim basis but but
you can't be doing this you did it last
year to us we gave you a new contract
here like this can't be have you can't
be the Aaron Rodgers of quarterbacks
where you're going yeah I don't know
give me a little bit of time I gotta ask
Sean McVay to make you give me a damn
answer right now and that's it and allow
us to move on Dan a couple things that
and here's the thing all this player
empowerment that I'm a little bit over
you guys get to decide what they want
where they want to trade to I'm not
buying the coach empowerment and this
now I love Sean McBeth I think he's a
hell of a coach but guess what we're all
replaceable and if he comes in and still
hymns and Haws down to your point guess
what I'll make the decision for him I I
will because there's listen there's guys
out there and I know the broadcast
saying any he's in his 30s and he's a
hot commodity and he's a great coach but
didn't Les Sneed and the ownership give
up every asset on the planet to get Sean
Payton what he wanted and he wanted some
Super Bowl with it yeah I mean Sean
McVay yes Sean McVay to get him what he
wanted and get a Super Bowl so now that
we robbed Peter we got to pay Paul I
need a decision and I need it
immediately because if you do if he's
not all in Dan I can tell you this
they're not going to be back in the
playoffs they they will they and they're
begging for assets now anyway because
some of their guys are getting older
some of their players are facing that
decision and Matt Stafford's coming off
an injury so you're damn right we gave
you what you wanted now we're asking for
a meeting and we're not the doors are
locked until you give us a yes or no and
if it's a kind of I'll help make the
decision for you as much as I like Sean
McVay you don't get to hold my franchise
hostage we're struggling enough this
year to find enough players and assets
to build for a future we got our ring
that doesn't mean you get to hold a
sausage I 100 agree with you all right
Paulie the rookie quarterback playoff
quiz we'll play that with Sean okay uh
recently a lot of quarterbacks in the
rookie year made the playoffs Mac Jones
last year but um there have been 28
quarterbacks since 1982 start a playoff
game as a rookie so I'm gonna go a
decade by decade and just give you a
couple notes a couple guys have won two
playoff games as rookies and if you can
guess that that'd be very tough
um give me an 80s quarterback who
started as a rookie in the playoffs
uh did mourinho's team make the playoffs
as a rookie I know a second year they
went to the Super correct Sean Dan
Marino okay 1983. I'll give you a hint
that's one that's hard to get Dieter
Brock of the Rams oh came from the CFL
Sean your kind of guy he started two
games for the Rams in the 85-86 playoffs
Dieter brought number five does that
sound yes and when when when you cflers
come to the NFL you throw out all the
records okay that's a great cup Legend
talk okay so Dieter Brock Dan Marino one
more from the 80s he was just fired for
betting on a game
just fired for betting on a game oh it
was uh Bernie co-star yeah Bernardo
Kozar yeah greatest mechanics of all
time
[Laughter]
birdie was a guy who'd be here and he'd
come here and he'd say what do you do oh
great he was doing the no look pass
before Mahomes was Dan remember how I
could do Dan Marie Marino's Cadence yeah
let me show you one day when we're in
Live or maybe at the Super Bowl I can
give you Bernie Kozar better Knoll
number 20 can give you himself or was he
at 20 and Bernie 19 in the Pro 20 in
college give the audience a little bit
of your Dan Marino at the line line of
scrimmage well you know how Dan we hear
all the sound now at 119 and Aaron
Rodgers came well Mourinho was very
simple he was well ahead of it before
the times he'd be like Mike is right
Mike right and he'd be licking his
fingers about 14 times while he was
saying it Mike right and he'd pop back
in the gun and he'd say Mike Mike's 55
down set and we're on three
so 180.
it's like Dan you said three yeah just
so what you do you'd snap it on the
first one to get to the tattoo yeah what
are you saying and it was never hot
yeah my guy and Danny D all red-faced
and he dropped back it couldn't move
three inches and he'd throw for 600
yards on it so all right do we have uh
the 90s now the 90s Dan I'll give you uh
Jim Everett also started as a rookie uh
for the Rams in the 80s in the 90s only
one quarterback as a rookie started in
the playoffs it was for the Raiders in
1991 that's how big of a hint I can give
you it couldn't have been Jaybird
Schroeder because he came out a lot
earlier than that
um 91 can you can you give me the
college your college
my college Vince Evans Todd marinovich
here I am saying fifth Savage who's
older than me and I got him started as a
rookie in the 90s but Vince did play for
the yeah marinovich that's right who
came out as a true sophomore I think to
play for the Raiders right I mean
remember that dude he was that's right
because that was the time we didn't have
to be on campus yeah that's exactly
right what else do we have let's get to
the 90s uh no that was the 90s okay
sorry the 2000s okay uh one from Tampa
one from Pittsburgh
one for Atlanta and one for Baltimore
and a couple guys multiple multiple
starts as rookies gosh dang
um who did uh from Cal for Baltimore
bowler Kyle bowler nope Joe Flacco as a
rookie in 09 started three playoff games
yeah Seton wow Ben Roethlisberger that's
correct two players okay give me the
other teams give me the other teams
Atlanta 2009.
Atlanta 2000 and Matt Ryan Matt Ryan's
correct well that had to be him
considering the length of his career
good call Tampa in 2000 scrambling
quarterback I think out of two lane
Sean King Sean King is correct started
two playoff games got a win for Tampa
nice okay now in the 2000s there's been
a bunch but here's the here's the one is
this the 2010s yeah 2010s all right this
quarterback in his rookie year started
three playoff games the most of anybody
and one two of them
and he's also from USC
uh well let's see Carson Palmer 2010.
they went to the AFC Championship game
yeah Mark Sanchez Rex Ryan is their
coach and I believe they led the league
in rushing
um and wasn't Marty schottenheimer's son
that's right the offensive coordinator
on those teams the Sean green years that
Mark Sanchez
like I went in Downton
throw out the record when USC
quarterbacks come to the playoffs except
of course mine yeah does anyone want
another shot at a random one here's some
random ones for the past 10 years Connor
Cook started for the Raiders in a
playoff game okay against the Texans
when Derek Carr was having an empty
season and he couldn't throw the ball in
the ocean if he was standing in a boat
that day tj8 oh that you I was gonna go
with oh a couple Playoff starts CJ Yates
and then haha Andrew
as a rookie what's wrong
I wasn't that young all he does is
Andrew Luck impersonation Sean Salisbury
loved him at USC big Gunslinger London
and Canada love Canadian Arts
he did that to he did that to Andrew
Luck I said you got to do your
impersonation Andrew Luck I got my new
flip phone it's a Nokia the Nokia 3
Series
the laugh at the end
Salisbury it's a steak it's not a person
it's a fine steak any other uh is that
it we're done with the Mark Jones from R
Jackson Dak Prescott Russell Wilson Jr
III and Robert Griffin Robert Griffith
Jr III when Bob Griffin was a rookie he
was off the charts now yeah he could run
off the table a little bit he could go a
little bit all right we'll see you in
Arizona
can't wait love you guys thank you
that's Sean Salisbury oh